اخذت التوترات وبين الصين وتايوان منحا
جديدا مع ابلاغ الاخيره عن مناورات عسكريه
اجرتها بكين نهايه الاسبوع وصفت بالاكبر
حتى لحظه الدفاع التايوانيه قالت ان الجيش
الصيني ارسل اكثر من 70 طائره مقاتله وسبع
سفن باتجاه تايوان من بينها 47 طائره عبرت
خط المنتصف بمضيق تايوان وهو حدود غير
رسميه قبلها الجانبان ضنيا من بين
الطائرات التي ارسلتها الصين نحو تايوان
18 طائره مقاتله من طراز جي 16 و11 مقاتله
من طراز جي 1 وست مقاتلات من طراز سو 30
التي تعد الاكثر تقدما اعزت الصين
تدريباتها العسكريه الاخيره التي ركزت على
توجيه ضربات في البحر والمجال الجوي قرب
تايوان الى ما وصفته باستفزازات والولايات
المتحده لم تخفي الصين قها من تنام
التعاون العسكري بين واشنطن وتيبي حيث
انتقدت مشروع قانون الانفاق الدفاعي
الامريكيه السنوي والذي يعتمدته اداره جو
بايدن باعتباره استفزازا سياسيا وكثفت
الصين من مناوراتها الحربيه حول تايوان
منذ اغسط الماضي في اعقابي زياره اثاره
الكثير من الجدل قامت بها رئيسه مجلس
النواب الامريكي نانسي بوليسي حيث تنظر
الصين الى زيارات الحكومات الاجنبيه
لتايوان على انها اعتراف فعليا بالجزيره
وتحدي لمطالبتها بالسياده عليها رشا خياط
العربيه